seven-year-old girl from las vegas is
still in a coma tonight
after a jet ski accident that happened
over the weekend this happened
saturday evening in the colorado river
right near bullhead city arizona about
100 miles southeast of las vegas
orco mana spoke exclusively to the
family's attorney and joins us now live
in studio
with more details brian and denise that
little girl is
fighting for her life tonight she's
recovering at a las vegas hospital right
now
and while police pieced together exactly
what happened
loved ones are praying for a speedy
recovery
this is every parent's worst nightmare a
family trip
turns terrifying authorities in arizona
say a little girl was critically injured
last weekend in a jet ski accident her
family has identified her as
seven-year-old las vegan isabella
bohannon
according to bullhead city police she
was waiting in the waters of the
colorado river when a jet ski operator
lost control and hit her
along with her mother and 12-year-old
sister isabella airlifted to the icu at
sunrise children's hospital suffering
from severe head trauma
she's still in a medically induced coma
speaking exclusively to 8 news now on
behalf of the family
attorney glenn lerner says they're
looking into their legal options but
right now the focus is on isabella let's
just make sure this little girl
lives and that she can hopefully come
back to leave
a normal life in the life that she was
going to leave a few days ago
bullhead city police say the jet ski
reportedly stalled and the operator
is being cooperative police telling me
they're still waiting for the blood test
results
we have a lot of questions here we'll
wait till we get the
police report hopefully that will be
pretty soon while the crash remains
under investigation lerner says he'll
take action if necessary
we'll do whatever we can to help this
family
now a gofundme page has been set up by
loved ones to help pay for isabella's
hospital bills
if you'd like to help we have a link to
that on our website 8newsnow.com
back to you